[Applause]
some of you I was on The Today Show and
this was before it was announced and it
was in the works and nobody knew and you
and Kathy were like you should have it
was like we but I have to say we
predicted you diddly was going to have a
show a long time ago you're nuts you
showed up on our set and you lit the
place like nobody ever liked what's
gonna happen and when Kathie Lee was
leaving remember yeah we were like
what's gonna happen we were unclear I
know and here's the sad thing like I was
like wait I didn't realize at the time
that she was leaving and I was like I
kind of maybe gotten to work with you
and then I was like wait you wake up
really early nope you've been I have to
tell you we watch you all the time
they've been amazing and I'm so happy
for you I can't even express now you
work with my other Texas Queen jealous
the shaker is praying so fun is well
hashtag wine let's do this yep I mean
because you get to run your show
this is actually pretty cool let's just
front my friends an ACME wine okay it's
it's a Matt Morris
I think it's called Charbonneau look at
you I know I don't even know what it is
it's actually a female just one like
winemaker of the year so it's really
amazing we both like wine we both love
supporting females I thought it worked
by the way this is perfect it's so good
well I think my people learned mom is a
lightweight and and like they have you
know you have your demos well I thought
at first it was gonna be like fake like
water Europe nope it's real so everybody
brings their like alcohol on it you're
like you know try it and then like
literally I'm like hot and I'm like
focus I'm like such a lightweight it's
like no matter how much I drink in life
I will never be able to drink more than
one or two glasses or it's like hold my
hair my husband's worst night ever so
but wait it's you have a new show and
you're you and Jenna you're going in
front of a live audience now well we
took a page from you this is perfect so
today was our very first day of having a
live audience and I have to say we have
like I love this vibe I love the vibe
you have on your show and Jenna and I
have always said like we love our
cameraman rope and Anthony we love them
we love the off of them is something
about having like our people with us an
energy yes yeah so we've been excited
about this we want to do it five days a
week we're gonna start with two just to
get it going and and we're pumped man we
feel like it's gonna be a good
they wrote it for years on Tamina it's
awesome to get give people a chance to
be in the same room with you and like
feed off your energy and and you're kind
of like me you talked to everyone and so
it's Jenna so you're gonna love it
I can't wait so great I can't wait yes I
love I feed off the energy as well but
how is becoming a mom changed you though
because you love kids now you have your
second baby yeah I know what Kelly it's
like that thank you
I keep trying to remember my life before
them oh and I can't it is so I feel like
it all started and it was it's so
strange to even think this but I
remember the first time someone asked me
I was walking to Duane Reade after I
just adopted Haley and I'd been my whole
life people had asked me the question do
you have children and I've always said
oh I have two nieces and I remembered
saying it in my sleep and I love my
niece - oh my niece yeah so I was
walking and she said you have children I
hadn't like told anybody and I stopped
and I said I have a daughter and she
like wow but she looked at me and I said
I'm daughter I kept repeating it I have
a daughter
and it was so profound to me in that
moment and when we were thinking about
whether we should adopt another child I
mean there are pluses to having children
late in life and obviously there are
minuses but I kept thinking I want
someone to hold hands with I want these
to dab someone to hold hands with all
the way like they have older parents and
I know that that's the way life goes but
I want to know when they are later on in
life there's somebody who says I
remember like I remember yeah my god we
had two older we have two younger and I
was like I hated pregnancy but I was
like God I don't want to be alone you
know I don't want her I was alone a lot
as a kid I was like I don't want her to
do that you know she wants is I'm nuts
and I don't want to be nice but the
other news wait this is actually
fantastic I have thought
like your new engage and I'm like
congratulations like you're on vacation
or something like I want your life and
and then like I thought you were married
this whole time yes you know what's
never like oh she got engaged I was like
did another or like if she's divorcing
why what you know what
Joel I met Joel like randomly at a book
signing one day one like six years ago
and it was one of those crazy nights
that you're so happy you went out we
started dating and a few years in I all
I was thinking about was having kids and
I couldn't push it away and when I asked
him and I brought this up I said I can't
push it away anymore I said I have to
ask you this important question and I I
said could will you explore adoption
with me and literally without blinking
without pausing he looked at me and he
said yes yes the married part I was like
okay well we're in love we have two kids
like who cares it did matter to him I
think a lot yeah and one day we were at
the beach and it was just the two of us
having a mom and dad trip and he started
giving love mom and dad trips
kela and churros
[Applause]
I love an adult trip and he was kind of
giving a little a little like love
speech which she does sometimes like I
just let's talk about where we are and I
love when he does that and I was like oh
that's so cute and I had another tequila
and was like looking up and then he was
like and he goes I really have something
important that I'd like to sass and yes
I love all of your talks about love yes
the chair out and he got on it and he
was he was crying and I was crying and I
didn't even he goes did you say yes I
said did you ask but anyway and in that
moment I thought I'd feel like I did the
day before cuz I already loved him but I
had no idea how profound saying
something out loud is like that telling
other people there's something to do
that as well cuz I was like you I would
well first of all my mom is still
shocked that I'm married and have
children I just didn't think I was gonna
happen but it's just one of those things
that you know didn't matter to me as
much as it mattered to my husband he had
kids yes you know and he thought I don't
know I think it's important you know and
I was like oh I'm cold and then he'd be
no pop the question one day but once it
does happen you're like oh no that is
different it's different than just being
together and in love it's a really cool
declaration in front of everyone and you
know just real like no hell no stay away
from my man you know it's a nice thing a
ring you know what does change I didn't
know so we're like here we go look at
that I just love that you've been
married in my world for years well I was
married once Bush I was no I thought oh
because you send me videos by the way I
love drunk texting Kelly
what is she do know I have a few friends
and the limelight that randomly do the
comics or one as well and it is hot
great yeah I should not do this this is
blackmail I never do that I'm afraid
people will show it never send that to
Blake Shelton oh never I know you love
Blake but he know he never trust him
with something important what did he do
I just don't trust him I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this